selon plusieurs études sur
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin la coved 19
davantage touché les femmes
entrepreneurs que les hommes à plusieurs
d'entre elles qui n'ont pas eu accès au
programme dette des gouvernements et une
sur cinq estiment ne pas pouvoir se
relever dans cette crise il ya quand
même plusieurs éléments encourageants
dans les statistiques récentes
on en parle avec séverine labels et les
pdg de femmes et sortent d'un organisme
qui est dédiée au développement de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
bonsoir bonsoir madame l'appel bonsoir
madame c'est par nos alors on va se
concentrer sur les bonnes nouvelles en
premier si vous le voulez bien il ya un
rapport du gouvernement fédéral cette
semaine sur les femmes en
entrepreneuriat qui révèle plusieurs
avancées qu'elles sont les plus grands
progrès qu'on note ce qui est vraiment
intéressant de noter c'est que depuis
les dix dernières années les femmes sont
trois fois plus nombreuses qu'en 2010 en
2007 à vouloir en affaires et elles sont
plus nombreuses que les hommes à se
mettre en action d'ailleurs et la
nouvelle génération d'entrepreneurs et
létalité paritaire avant lakovic 19 une
autre très bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on
voit une accélération des femmes dans le
domaine de l'exportation elles sont deux
fois plus nombreuses qu'avant a exporté
donc ce aussi que des bonnes nouvelles
et ça s'explique par deux choses
premièrement les femmes sont plus
tendance désormais à générer de la
croissance au sein de leurs entreprises
et elles sont aussi plus nombreuses dans
le secteur d'une même facture est donc
encore là une excellente nouvelle pour
des chiffres comme ça on en a plein dans
le rapport on dit que les entreprises
qui sont détenues majoritairement par
des femmes
le nombre a augmenté de 50% en trois ans
on a vraiment l'impression que les
femmes sont en train de devenir une
force motrice la de l'économie
canadienne définitivement puis
d'ailleurs dans le rapport on nomme
laporte pourrait avoir au sein du pib
l'entreprenariat féminin situent les
femmes entreprenait au même niveau que
les hommes on parle de centaines de
milliards de dollars de plus pour
l'économie canadienne
bon évidemment tout n'est pas facile
tout n'est pas rose il y avait des défis
même avant la pandémie les entreprises
de plus par des femmes en général des
revenus moins élevés ce sont
généralement de plus petites entreprises
la très très grande majorité à plus de
97 % des entreprises à propriété
féminine compte moins de 20 employés
ce sont deux plus petites entreprises et
elles sont massivement au sein de
secteurs d'activités qui sont
particulièrement touchés par la copie 19
ans qui évidemment les services et
services à la personne l'hébergement la
restauration le commerce de détail ce
sont tous des secteurs où les femmes
sont très près oui c'est probablement
une des raison madame label pour lequel
le choc économique est encore plus vive
pour les entrepreneurs ou féminin dans
une cadre de cette pandémie
définitivement autant la grandeur des
entreprises ont en fait on quand on aime
plus petites entreprises souvent on a
peut-être un peu moins de moyens
financiers plus loin de poussins pour
faire face à une crise comme celle là
est évidemment quand on travaille dans
le secteur particulièrement affecté on
le sait le milieu de la restauration
pour ne nommer que ce que ce secteur est
ça a été très difficile mais on a
d'autres aussi le milieu des arts de la
culture tout le secteur touristique et
les soins à la personne ont été
directement touchées
et qu'est-ce qu'il ya de nombreux défis
évidemment pour toutes les entreprises
mais à quel défiler les femmes
entrepreneurs sont elles plus confrontés
que les hommes un contexte actuel j'ai
d'autres espèces de parler de ça mais je
vais nommer quand même parce que c'est
pas été relevé à travers une étude
pancanadienne
les femmes se sont retrouvées veut pas
avec une grande charge de travail à la
maison donc la charge domestique
s'occuper des enfants aussi qu'ils
étaient à la maison donc évidemment de
conjuguer la conciliation travail
famille c'est toujours un défi dans
l'est
femme me parlent et je pense qu'en
contexte de pandémie ça c'est
définitivement exacerbée c'est un autre
défi qui est vraiment pardon à lévis qui
est vraiment important c'est celui de
l'accès aux financements je tiens à en
parler parce que l on traverse fois même
le rapport dia le démontrent les femmes
sont portés à investir leur propre
argent
et quand elles vont cogner aux portes
des instances financières c'est toujours
un peu plus compliqué pour elle et
notamment les femmes issues de la
diversité de la diversité culturelle il
ya toujours des obstacles des barrières
à systémique
bon vous avez une organisation femmes
essor quelles sont les mesures que vous
mettez de l'avant pour favoriser
l'entreprenariat féminin mais en est une
organisation kurde du financement et de
l'accompagnement donc évidemment du
financement pour le démarrage à 306
l'acquisition d'entreprises dédiées
d'abord une femme qui détient au moins
25% des parts d'une entreprise à ça
vient un accompagnement qui est très
soutenu et toute une panoplie d'experts
qu'on met à la disposition des femmes
entrepreneurs sont refinancées par
l'entremise de 900 le font les femmes
entrepreneures ffq et c'est un
accompagnement qui a fait ses preuves
puisque madame s'est emmené aux 80 pour
ça les entreprises qui ont un
financement à travers l'entremise de
famille s'en sont aujourd'hui en
activité après cinq ans d'activité donc
ses mains supérieure à la moyenne
il nous reste quelques secondes est ce
que vous avez moins de demandes
d'accompagnement en ce moment où plus
madame label définitivement plus les
femmes ont besoin d'accompagnement pour
adapter leur modèle d'affaires à la
situation actuelle on compte neuf
énormément d'accompagnement pour les uns
gagnent vivotech beaucoup des travaux
personnels mais oui comme un même label
merci à vous vendre un toit